[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace centroamérica en
esta oportunidad desde antigua guatemala
en nuestro primer tema revisaremos la
reciente e histórica victoria ante los
altos tribunales de las mujeres
indígenas maya achí que fueron violadas
durante la guerra civil guatemalteca a
finales del siglo 20 el castigo contra
los cinco ex paramilitares imputados fue
de 30 años de prisión inconmutables por
haber cometido los crímenes de violación
sistemática y esclavitud sexual a 36
mujeres del municipio rabín al
departamento de baja verapaz aunque para
las víctimas se constituye como un
triunfo y una reivindicación de la
justicia para las abogadas también
indígenas mayas la pena quedó corta
del otro lado de la orilla revisaremos
el panorama migratorio en guatemala y
para dimensionar la magnitud del
problema miraremos de cerca las cifras
de los guatemaltecos repatriados
retornados desde eeuu y méxico en lo
corrido de la pandemia también
explicaremos la reciente reforma a la
ley de migración aprobada en el congreso
de la república que endurece las penas
contra los denominados coyotes los
traficantes de personas que en múltiples
oportunidades infligen tratos crueles e
inhumanos a los migrantes indocumentados
los maya habitan toda guatemala y
representan la identidad del país por su
sabiduría y su cultura milenaria pero en
tiempos de la guerra civil guatemalteca
sufrieron un cúmulo de atrocidades
durante largos 36 años y justamente esta
cifra coincide con nuestro primer tema
porque fueron 36 las mujeres indígenas
maya achí quienes recientemente ganaron
un juicio mediático tras haber sido
violadas por cinco paramilitares en la
en 1980
esta casa de la capital de guatemala es
la sede de la ong internacional impunity
watch espacio determinante para la
construcción de los argumentos y la
recopilación de pruebas del caso hay de
vale y perteneciente a la misma
comunidad maya achí que sufrió los de
hameen es en el municipio de rabinal
hace parte del bufete de tres abogadas
indígenas que logró hacer justicia 40
años después de los hechos un reto que
comenzó con las narraciones de las
mujeres agredidas la apertura del caso
en el 2011
en primer lugar hay que entender que
para una mujer hablar sobre la violencia
sexual es un paso difícil de dar por
todo el estigma que hay alrededor de
esos hechos y porque
frecuentemente se le culpa a la mujer
sobre lo que ella ella le ocurre y más
cuando se trata de violencia sexual al
constituir los relatos de las víctimas
las indígenas repetían la frase pasaron
sobre mí porque en su lengua maya no
existe la palabra violación
pero sin duda fueron las declaraciones
de las sobrevivientes ante los
tribunales de mayor riesgo creados a
comienzos del siglo 21 la pieza clave
para convencer a la terna de jueces en
parte por la jurisprudencia del sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos que
reconoce el valor intrínseco de los
testimonios de las víctimas de violencia
sexual así lo relata doña antonia una de
las 36 mujeres que ganaron el caso
contra sus agresores
y gracias por la jueza también creyó
nuestros testimonios como mujeres valero
y creyó lo que nosotros sufrimos
para mí pues de qué
y si hay más mujeres que no han
denunciado que de no ser porque todos
tenemos derechos ahora entremos en
materia de inmigración guatemala es uno
de los tres países del denominado
triángulo norte de centroamérica que no
se escapa del éxodo de miles de sus
habitantes con rumbo hacia eeuu para
cumplir el sueño americano cuáles son
sus motivos así nos lo explicó danilo
ribera experto en temas de migración de
guatemala
los efectos económicos de violencia
que se ha generado a partir de la
pandemia veamos que efectivamente se ha
encarecido la canasta básica y por otro
lado pues a pesar de que hay mucha
remesa las personas que siguen migrando
porque no encuentran trabajo en mucho
desempleo aunque es difícil determinar
cuántos guatemaltecos migran al año se
puede tener una idea del fenómeno a
partir de las cifras de los nacionales
deportados desde méxico y eeuu
según datos del instituto guatemalteco
de emigración en los cerca de 2 años de
la pandemia de kobe 19 109 mil
guatemaltecos fueron retornados tanto
por la vía aérea desde eeuu como por la
vía terrestre desde en méxico
recientemente el pasado primero de
febrero el congreso aprobó una reforma a
la ley de inmigración para endurecer las
penas contra los coyotes los traficantes
de personas
en síntesis y antiguamente la justicia
guatemalteca castigaba con un máximo de
8 años de prisión a los coyotes ahora
con la nueva reforma de la ley
migratoria se impondrán castigos y penas
de hasta 30 años de prisión en casos
como por ejemplo el de la masacre de
tamaulipas ocurrido en enero de 2021 en
el cual fueron encontrados en la
frontera entre méxico y eeuu 19 cuerpos
calcinados de los cuales 16 de ellos
eran migrantes guatemaltecos una
realidad dolorosa que no sólo afecta a
guatemala sino a los otros dos países
del triángulo norte honduras y el
salvador gracias por acompañarnos en
este enlace centroamérica desde antigua
guatemala soy andrés suárez jaramillo en
la cámara mi colega aurora valle
recuerde que si quieres repetir este
episodio lo puede encontrar en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom hasta pronto